bueno acabo de terminar
el último encuentro
de esta semana de largo viaje de esta
semana de la cumbre eeuu luz y dice que
hay mucha emoción detrás de esa reunión
pero fue bastante directa para mí en
primer lugar no hay ningún sustituto
como ustedes lo saben para el diálogo
entre líderes cara a cara el presidente
putin y yo
compartimos una responsabilidad única
administrar la relación entre dos países
poderosos y orgullosos una relación que
debe ser estable y predecible nosotros
deberíamos poder cooperar donde esté
nuestro interés comunidad y donde
tenemos diferencias quiero que el
presidente putin entienda por qué digo
lo que digo y por qué hago lo que hago
y cómo responderemos a acciones
específicas que hieran los intereses
estadounidenses
ahora le dije al presidente putin que mi
agenda no es en contra de rusia o
cualquier otra entidad sino por hacia el
polo estadounidense lucharé contra kobe
19 reconstruir nuestra economía
reestablecer las relaciones alrededor
del mundo con aliados y amigos y
proteger al pueblo estadounidense esa es
mi responsabilidad como presidente
también le dije que ningún presidente de
los eeuu
podría mantener su fe dentro del pool
estadounidense si no pueden hablar para
defender los valores democráticos para
defender las libertades fundamentales
que todos los hombres y mujeres tienen
en nuestra perspectiva eso es parte del
adn de nuestro país así que los derechos
humanos siempre van a estar en la mesa
eso fue lo que le dije no se trata
solamente de perseguir a rusia cuando
violen los derechos humanos se trata de
quiénes somos cómo podría yo ser el
presidente de los estados unidos de
américa y no defender la vida no hablar
en contra de la violación de los
derechos humanos yo le dije a él que
aprecia otros países incluyendo a rusia
somos un producto único de una idea
usted me ha escuchado decir esto antes
una y otra vez y lo seguiré diciendo fue
una idea nosotros no sacamos nuestro
derechos a partir del gobierno los
tenemos porque nacimos con ellos
punto
y los defendemos frente un gobierno así
fue como se lo dije a él por eso es que
vamos siempre levantar nuestras
preocupaciones sobre temas como el de
alexéi navalni lo deje claro al
presidente putin seguiremos denunciando
situaciones de violación derechos
humanos porque eso es lo que somos esa
es la idea de que tenemos estas verdades
como evidencias de que todos los hombres
y mujeres hemos vivido a la altura de
esto pero siempre hemos tratado de
ampliar el arco del compromiso e incluir
más y más personas dice también la
denuncia de dos ciudadanos
estadounidenses presos sin razón justa
con webber y trouble ring también
denuncia el tema de radio frío y radio
filiberti y la importancia de una prensa
libre y de la libertad de prensa deje
claro que no vamos a tolerar intensos de
violar nuestra soberanía democrática o
desestabilizar nuestros derechos
colectivos y responderemos
el punto es que le dije al presidente
putin que necesitamos reglas claras y
básicas que todos vamos a cumplir
también dije que hay áreas donde hay un
interés mutuo a la hora de cooperar para
nuestra gente la gente rusa la gente
estadounidense pero también para el
beneficio del resto del mundo y su
seguridad una de esas áreas es la
estabilidad estratégica usted usted me
ha preguntado en el veces que era lo que
yo iba a discutir con putin antes de
venir yo les dije que solamente negoció
con el individuo ahora puedo decirles
que era lo que pretendía hacer desde el
principio y eso es discutir y denunciar
los temas de la estabilidad estratégica
y tratar de establecer un mecanismo con
el cual iremos y discutimos en detalle
los planes y los pasos que vamos a tomar
para reducir los riesgos de conflicto me
complace haber acordado hoy lanzar un
diálogo estratégico bilateral es la
palabra y pro médica para hacer que
nuestros expertos militares y nuestros
expertos diplomáticos se reúnen para
trabajar en un mecanismo que pueda
llevar
de armas nuevas sofisticadas y
peligrosas que están ahora en la escena
que reducen los tiempos de respuesta que
despiertan los prospectos de una guerra
accidental y pasamos por detalle sobre
el curso de esos sistemas otra área en
la cual pasamos mucho tiempo discutiendo
fue la ciberseguridad hablé de la
propuesta de cierta de que cierta
estructura crítica de estar fuera de los
límites del ataque punto seas
ciberataques o cualquier tipo de ataque
le dio una lista no tengo del isr estos
momentos es lista de 16 es entidades
específicas 16 entidades definidas como
infraestructura crítica bajo la ley de
eeuu del sector energético hasta
nuestros sistemas de agua por supuesto
en principio es uno esto debe ser
respaldado por la práctica los países
responsables debe tomar acciones en
contra de los criminales que lleven a
cabo actividades de ransomware en su
territorio hemos acordado
enviar expertos a trabajar en el
entendimiento específico sobre todo lo
que está fuera del lugar de hacer
seguimientos sobre casos específicos que
se originaron en otros países en
cualquiera de nuestros países hay una
larga lista de otras cosas en las que
hemos pasado tiempo desde la necesidad
ingente de preservar los pasos
humanitarios en síria para llevar comida
simplemente comida necesidades básicas a
las personas que están muriendo de
hambre cómo construirlo y cómo esto
funciona los intereses de rus y de eeuu
para asegurarnos que irán
no adquiera armas nucleares acordamos
trabajar juntos aquí porque está en
nuestros intereses mutuos y como
asegurar que el ártico permanezca como
una región de cooperación en vez de
conflicto y parte de la intervención del
presidente putin y él habló sobre la
necesidad de que nosotros fuésemos
capaces de tener un modus operandi donde
nos aseguremos de que el ártico fuera
realmente una zona libre y como cada uno
de nosotros puede contribuir a este
esfuerzo conjunto de impedir la
resurgencia del terrorismo en afganistán
claramente está en los intereses de
rusia no tener una resurgencia del
terrorismo en afganistán también hay
áreas que son más desafiantes y se
comunique
el compromiso de eeuu a la soberanía y
la integridad territorial de ucrania
acordamos buscar caminos diplomáticos
respecto de la cuerda de misa y les
aseguro que nuestras les asegure le
insistiera esas preocupaciones sobre
bielorrusia no estuvo en desacuerdo con
lo que pasó simplemente dijo que es una
perspectiva de qué hacer al respecto sé
que muchos tienen preguntas entonces
quiero cerrar con eso
fue importante para fue importante
encontrarnos en persona para que no
hubiera ningún tipo de error o ninguna
mala representación de lo que yo quería
comunicar hice lo que vine a hacer en
primer lugar identificar áreas de
trabajo práctico donde nuestros países
pueden lograr avances en intereses
mutuos y también beneficiar al mundo 2
comunicar directamente directamente de
que los estados unidos responderán a
acciones que pongan en peligro nuestros
intereses o el interés de nuestros
aliados y en tercer lugar trazar
claramente las prioridades de nuestros
países y nuestros valores para bueno él
lo escuchó directamente de mi parte y
debo decirles que el tono de toda la
reunión creo que fue un total de 4 horas
fue bueno positivo no hubo
ningún tipo de acción estridente que
fuese tomada donde hubo desacuerdo hubo
desacuerdo y que donde estuve donde
estuvo el desacuerdo él se lo declaró
pero no fue hecho de una manera
hiperbólica eso ha pasado mucho
durante esta última semana creo y espero
que los eeuu haya mostrado el mundo que
estamos de vuelta juntos junto a
nuestros aliados junto a las democracias
que están alrededor nuestro hacer
compromisos grandes para asumir los
grandes desafíos que nuestro mundo
enfrenta y ahora hemos establecido una
base clara sobre cómo pretendemos lidiar
con rusia y la relación estados
unidos-rusia hay mucho trabajo para
hacer no sugiero que eso se haya logrado
pero hemos logrado mucho en este viaje y
antes de responder sus preguntas quiero
decir una última cosa señores miren esto
y eso trata de cómo pasamos de aquí en
adelante escuche de nuevo una gran parte
de lo que fue la conferencia del
presidente putin y como él resaltó eso
trata de decisiones prácticas sensatas
que debemos tomar uno tomar y ya lo
descubriremos en los próximos seis meses
o un año si de hecho tenemos un diálogo
estratégico que sea relevante ya lo
descubriremos si hemos logrado trabajar
y lidiar con todo desde la liberación de
personas en prisiones rusas ya lo
descubriremos si tenemos un acuerdo de
ciberseguridad que empiece a traer algo
de orden miren los países
que puede resultar dañado si no logramos
estos son grandes países
por ejemplo cuando hablaba del oleoducto
con el trabajo pues con el ataque
ransomware le pregunté al presidente
cómo se sentiría usted si este
ransomware se tomara los l ductos de sus
campos petroleros él dijo que sería algo
importante esto no se trata solo de
nuestros intereses se trata de un
interés mutuo ha sido sus preguntas como
es usuario me han dado una lista de las
personas a las cuales va a llamar
entonces jonathan the associated press
gracias
se intentó interferir en las últimas
elecciones presidenciales y que el grupo
de cursos están detrás de hackeos como
solarwinds y otros ataques de razón
porque se mencionado putin en su
conferencia no acepto ninguna
responsabilidad por cualquier mal
comportamiento su predecesor optó no
exigir que tuvo que putin que tuviera
estos ataques concretamente que pudo ha
logrado usted de que eso suceda antes
que esto suceda de nuevo y que amenazas
estado esté enfrentando sobre si lo
detuve impedir que pase de nuevo él ya
sabe que yo voy a tomar acción como ya
hicimos cuando ocurre la última vez lo
que sucedió fue que dejamos claro que no
íbamos a seguir permitir que eso
sucediera ya y permitido que eso
sucediera el resultado fue que
terminamos bueno retirando embajadores
cerrando algunas de sus instalaciones en
estados unidos etcétera él sabe que hay
consecuencias miren una de las
consecuencias que yo bueno no debería
decir esto hay unas cosas que ellos
supongo que ustedes creen que no
importan pero
hay algo que le importa a él ya otros
líderes mundiales de grandes naciones es
la credibilidad a nivel mundial porque
está reduciéndose dejemos esto muy claro
como sería si los eeuu fueron revisados
por el resto del mundo si se supiera que
interfirieran directamente con las
elecciones de otros países si todo el
mundo lo supiera cómo sería
si entramos a hacer actividades que él
ya ha hecho esto disminuye el escalafón
de un país que está desesperadamente
intentando mantenerlo como un gran poder
mundial
no se trata solo de lo que yo haga se
trata de que las acciones que otros
países toman en este caso rusia que
contradicen las normas internacionales y
hay un precio por pagar ahí
ellos no pueden dictar lo que puede
suceder en el mundo hay otras naciones
que tiene una consecuencia significativa
como los estados unidos de américa hay
un seguimiento
presidente salsa pregunta ustedes
hablaron mucho sobre derechos humanos
que diría usted si el líder de la
oposición a baltimore yo dejé claro a él
que yo creo en las consecuencias de eso
serían devastadoras para rusia voy a
volver al mismo punto que creía usted
qué sucedería cuando él dice que no se
trata de herir a nabai ni de todo lo que
él ha dicho para racionalizar el
tratamiento sobre navalny y luego él
muere en prisión
yo resalte el error saltea el que
importa bastante cuanto un país
realmente
me preguntan me preguntaron porque creía
que era importante
[Música]
teniendo problemas para el presidente de
siria es porque él está violando una ley
internacional se llama el trato de armas
químicas él no puede no se puede confiar
en él esto es de confianza se trata de
construir sobre la influencia a otros
países mira la pregunta de si tratarían
de cambiar la economía nuestra por la de
rus y quisieran intercambiarlo eso
nosotros discutimos esto al comercio yo
no tengo ningún problema con hacia
negocios con rusia
mientras lo hagan basados en el
internacional
está entre nuestros intereses es que la
gente de rusia está bien económicamente
no tengo problemas pero si ellos no
actúan de acuerdo con las normas
internacionales
bueno eso no va a pasar con nosotros no
va a pasar con otras naciones él habló
un poquito sobre eso sobre cómo había
una necesidad de llegar a otros países
para que inviertan en rusia
ningún país irás mientras estén
convencidos de que de hecho hay un
violación de derechos por ejemplo al
negociante estadounidense que estuvo en
arresto domiciliario yo yo se lo
mencioné usted quiere que los
comerciantes estadounidenses inviertan
déjelo ir cambie la dinámica porque los
negociantes estadounidenses no están
listos para llegar ahí no están listos
para quedarse moscú miren yo sé que
hemos hecho que la política
internacional sea una gran habilidad que
pareciera a veces común
código secreto la política es una
extensión de las relaciones personales
es como funciona naturales humanas y hay
que entender que cuando uno maneja un
país que no cumple las normas
internacionales pero aún así uno
necesita las normas internacionales para
estar a cargo para poder participar en
el beneficio de ellos esto no se lo
hubiera uno no es una respuesta
transitoria bayless dijo que invadiría
rusia no por cierto eso fue una broma
eso no es cierto pero mi punto genérico
es que es mucho más complicado devitt
sangre
gracias señor presidente previos a esta
discusión hubo muchas discusiones sobre
los dos países que podrían terminar en
una nueva guerra fría me pregunto si
hubo algo que saliera de esa discusión
que le hiciera usted creer eso primero
déjeme quitarme este abrigo porque está
haciendo sólo hay algo que lo haga creer
que el presidente putin haya decidido
alejarse de su rol fundamental como
mandatario disruptivo particularmente en
la otra en eeuu quisiera hacerle
seguimiento a la descripción sobre como
usted le dio una lista de impresión de
la crítica en los eeuu
detalló usted claramente cuál sería la
penalidad por interferir en esa empresa
autora critica dejo eso de una manera
vaga respondió a él
respecto a primero le señale significa
que tenemos unas capacidades
cibernéticas importantes él lo sabe él
lo sabe exactamente qué es pero es
significativa y de hecho si violan esas
normas básicas
nosotros vamos a respondernos
de manera irónica y él lo sabe de una
manera cibernética
bueno segundo lugar
yo creo que lo último que él quisiera
ahora es una guerra fría citándolo pero
no creo que sea apropiado voy a hacer
una ruptura pregunta retórica tiene una
frontera de muchas millas con china
china está dando pasos hacia adelante
buscando ser la economía más fuerte del
mundo la mayor la más con el ejército
más poderoso del mundo estamos en una
situación donde su economía está
luchando necesita que se mueva de una
manera más agresiva en términos de
crecimiento claro está
[Música]
guau
bueno y no creo que él esté buscando una
guerra fría con los eeuu no creo como le
dije a él le dije creo que su generación
y la mía
están a 10 años de distancia esto no es
un momento cumbayá como solíamos decir
en los 60s de abrazarnos llamarnos pero
no está en los intereses de todos
tenemos de su interés ni el mío están en
una situación donde terminemos en una
nueva guerra fría
yo creo que él entiende eso perfecta y
realmente pero eso no significa que él
esté dispuesto para bajar los brazos y
decir vengan él todavía creo que está
preocupado por ser encerrado el pse pero
él le preocupa que nosotros realmente
estemos buscando tomar lo de la
presidencia tiene esas preocupaciones
pero no creo que sean los grandes
motivadores de la relación que esté
buscando con los eeuu
jennifer lakers
gracias señor presidente hay una razón
particular por la cual esta cumbre duró
solamente tres horas sabemos que usted
habló de cuatro o cinco hubo alguna
razón por la cual se acortará también
presidente putin dijo que no había
amenazas o tácticas para asustar está
usted de acuerdo con que no hubo ningún
tipo de táctica también hablaron sobre
afganistán y una retiro seguro de las
tropas sí sí y si voy a volver a la
primera parte la razón por la cual no
duró más tiempo es porque la última vez
que dos jefes de estado pasaron más de
dos horas en una conversación directa
entrando en detalles específicos bueno
no puedo pensar en ninguno no nos
estamos a medida que llegó un grupo más
grande de nuestros
asistentes de defensa de inteligencia el
secretario de estado también estaba
conmigo conmigo nuestro embajador
etcétera llegaron todos habíamos ya
cubierto muchos temas entonces hubo una
especie de sumario hecho por él y por mí
sobre lo que ya habíamos cubierto
lávrov y blinken discutieron lo que ya
habíamos cubierto
hicimos nuestras solicitudes pedimos
amplificaciones nos pedimos nos
aseguramos de que no hubiera
malentendidos
fue después de dos horas que nos vimos y
dijimos bueno qué pasa qué viene después
qué va a pasar después
lo que va a pasar es que vamos a poder
mirar hacia atrás y mirar hacia delante
de aquí a 36 meses
y decir que las cosas que acordamos
discutir funcionaron
y luego veremos si estamos una cerca de
una estrategia de mayor estabilidad
estratégica un progreso en ese sentido
si estamos alineados en términos buenos
este va a ser el desafío es se va a
hacer la prueba no estoy diciendo nada
el presidente y yo que el presidente y
yo ya hemos dicho que vamos a cortar ese
queso a funcionar no he dicho eso lo que
siento es que hay un prospecto genuino
de mejorar significativamente las
relaciones entre nosotros países sin
ceder a nada basados en estos principios
y nuestros valores no hubo ningún tipo
de amenaza tampoco de hecho
[Música]
escuché que licitó a mi madre de citó a
otras personas hoy como dije fue algo
bastante sorprendente hablamos de cosas
básicas y fundamentales
ustedes saben cómo soy yo les explico
las cosas de una manera personal e
íntima qué pasaría si por ejemplo
entonces no hubo ningún tipo de amenaza
solo afirmaciones simples y nada es
bueno nosotros si tú haces eso nosotros
haremos eso no nada de eso simplemente
le dejamos saber cuál era mi posición
que creía que podíamos lograr juntos y
si hay violaciones de las obras en
estadounidense crearemos
el los preguntó por afganistán él dijo
que él dijo que esperaba que pudiésemos
mantener algún tipo de paz y seguridad y
dije que eso tenía mucho que ver con el
del índico que estaba preparado para
ayudar en afganistán y no entrar en
detalles y ayudar
en irán y ayudar de vuelta nosotros le
dijimos lo que queríamos hacer queríamos
algo de estabilidad y seguridad
económica cause seguridad física para la
gente de siria también vida de libia
fuimos a esas discusiones
a mí ya mis
gracias señor presidente usted dijo que
no dijo ninguna que no hubo ninguna
amenaza pero hubo algún ultimátum
respecto del ransomware dirán y como
mediría el éxito particularmente en
estos grupos de trabajo de interferencia
rusa y en ciberseguridad bueno va a ser
bastante fácil por ejemplo sobre
ciberseguridad si vamos a trabajar
cuando tomen acción sobre un ataque de
terrassa muerte iraní sobre el técnico
ruso ellos no lo hicieron y no creo que
los planearon en este caso van a actuar
bueno ya lo veremos nosotros nos
comprometimos a actuar en términos de
cualquier cosa que afectará violar a las
normas internacionales creo que tenemos
una oportunidad real de dar pasos hacia
adelante y creo que una de las cosas que
noté cuando tuvimos el encuentro más
grande es que las personas que están
bien informadas empezaron a pensar
que esto podría ser un gran problema qué
pasa si las instalaciones de ransomware
esther en florida o en maine y tomaran
acción como dije
en una línea vital de su economía como
el petróleo eso sería devastador y uno
pudo verlo es bueno nosotros no haríamos
eso pero no pudo verlos pensar en eso es
el interés de todos que esto funcione ya
veremos qué pasa con los grupos que
hemos reunido
la tercera ser presidente cuando
presidente putin fue cuestionado y sobre
derechos humanos dijo que la razón por
la cual está atacando a los opositores
es porque no quiere que algo en bruce ya
que algún pase en rusia como lo que pasó
en el 6 de enero habló también de blanc
time matters de la represión policial
cuáles son sus respuestas y mi respuesta
es parecía lo que haya comunicado y es
que es una comparación ridícula una cosa
es literalmente los criminales
que rompieron un cordón policial
entraron el capitolio matar a un policía
y que ellos sean responsables por ello y
otra cosa es que la gente objete y
marche en una capital diciendo que que
no se les permite hablar libremente que
no se les permite hacer otras cosas
hay criterios muy diferentes
steve holland de reuters
presidente putin dijo que estaba
satisfecho con la respuesta su
comentario de él bueno siendo un asesino
puede darme usted su perspectiva al
respecto él dijo que estaba satisfecho
porque voy a resaltar lo de luego
después de hablar con él cree usted que
puede confiar en él
esto no se trata de confianza esto es
jugar los intereses propios y la
verificación de esos va de eso se trata
virtualmente casi cualquier persona con
la cual logre un acuerdo que trabajará
en nombre de los intereses
estadounidenses ha dicho que confió en
el problema y ya veremos qué sucede
bueno ya veremos en un corto tiempo que
pasa el reino liberty hola señor
presidente puede ver desde ahí si no hay
ningún problema
y bueno creo que usted sabes
[Música]
por ejemplo radio free europe radio
liberty voice de américa
son cercanos al canal cual que trabajo
fueron designados como agentes foráneos
y hay otros medios independientes que
reciben lo mismo existe existentes está
forzando a salir de rusia 30 años
después de que el presidente nos
invitarán mi pregunta es que si después
de sus charlas con el presidente putin
que tan interesado cree usted que él
esté en mejorar el clima mediático en
rusia yo no lo pondría de esa manera en
términos de mejorar el clima de hecho lo
pondría en términos de que tanto interés
tiene él
pulir la reputación rusa
que ya es vista contraria a los
intereses de la libertad de prensa
no lo sé pero no creo que él esté
interesado en cambiar la naturaleza una
sociedad cerrada un gobierno cerrado en
las acciones relativas a lo que él cree
que es el derecho del gobierno de actuar
voy a hacer lo que hace
es un enfoque completamente diferente
he leído
la mayoría de cosas que él ha escrito
los discursos que él ha hecho
he leído un par de buenas biografías
alrededor de él muchos de ustedes
también lo han hecho y creo que se lo
resalta
rusia tuvo una oportunidad un momento
corto y brillante justo después de
gorbachov y de que la situación empezará
a cambiar básicamente de hecho se un
gobierno democrático pero lo que pasó
fue que fracasó
y un gran incremento entre los
intelectuales rusos para determinar qué
tipo de gobierno elegiría ni cómo lo
elegirían basada en lo que creía
el ser judío decidió que rusia siempre
había sido un gran poder internacional
cuando ha resultado completamente unido
como estado ruso no basado en ideologías
volviendo a los húsares a los comisarios
directamente hacia la revolución de 1817
a dónde están ahora ahora y creo que es
bastante claro para mí ya lo he dicho y
creo que lo decidió el camino de rusia
para sucederse a sí mismo es como un
gran poder y es a través de la unión del
pueblo ruso
alrededor de la fortaleza del gobierno y
el control del gobierno no
necesariamente ideológico sino del
gobierno y yo creo que esa fue la
elección que ellos tomaron
no voy a adivinar
si pudo haber sido fundamentalmente
diferente pero creo que eso no se presta
a que rusia se mantenga como los grandes
poderes del mundo
y la respuesta militar salió en esta
conversación en términos de las líneas
rojas que se transaron hay una opción de
que exista la respuesta militar un
ataque ransomware el presidente putin lo
había llamado en su conferencia de
prensa un político experimentado usted
dijo famosamente que él no tenía un alma
usted tiene en estos momentos un mayor
entendimiento de después de la reunión
muchas gracias
sobre la respuesta militar no no
hablamos sobre respuesta militar
usted dijo que no hay sustitutos para el
diálogo cara a cara y también respecto a
lo que usted ha dicho de que los mayores
problemas de la otan ahora son rusia y
china
usted dijo muchas veces como había
pasado posiblemente más tiempo con el
presidente de ti que cualquier otro
líder mundial entonces va a llegar un
momento en el que usted lo llame de
viejo a mi gobierno y le pida a abrir
china a la organización mundial de la
salud a los investigadores que están
llegando al intentan y acá al fondo del
comité mire nosotros conocemos bien pero
nosotros no somos viejos amigos quiero
dejarlo claro estos son sólo negocios mi
pregunta sería si ustedes presionaría al
cine
en el comunicado del g7 dijo que estaba
siendo llamado china para abrirse y
permitir que los investigadores llegarán
pero chino básicamente dice que no
quieren interferencias qué pasa ahora
el impacto la actitud de la actitud
asesina del mundo se desarrollará china
intentado fuertemente proyectarse como
un país responsable y una nación de
acciones directas
ellos hablan muy fuerte de cómo ayuda en
el mundo respecto del cobi 19 y las
vacunas están intentándolo con mucho
ahínco hay muchas cosas que uno no
debería explicarle a la gente del mundo
ellos ven los resultados
que si tienes está realmente intentando
llegar al fondo de esto hay una cosa que
si discutimos como les dije en la unión
europea y en el g 7 y en lo que
deberíamos estar haciendo y lo que voy a
buscar hacer es reunir al mundo para
trabajar sobre lo que va a ser el
mecanismo físico disponible para
detectar de manera temprana la próxima
pandemia tener un mecanismo mediante el
cual podemos responder a ella y
responder tempranamente esto va a
suceder va a suceder que necesitamos
hacerlo muchas gracias